Speaker 1: . We're continuing to learn more
and more about the proximity, the the proximity
to a coup that took place with Donald Trump
in those late days of his administration.
I don't want to spend a lot of time on this,
but indeed we are.
We are learning that that coup was much closer
than we thought.
Much of this relates to statements by General
Mark Milley that we now know about because
of the book from Carol Leonnig and Philip
Rucker.
Report from CNN.
The top U.S. military officer, chairman of
the Joint Chiefs, General Mark Milley, was
so shaken that then President Donald Trump
and his allies might attempt a coup or take
other dangerous or illegal measures after
the November election that Millie and other
top officials informally planned for different
ways to stop Trump, according to excerpts
of an upcoming book obtained by CNN.
They were so worried they actually got together
and said, how do we stop a Trump coup if he
attempts it?
It was a kind of Saturday night massacre in
reverse, Leonnig and Rucker write.
The book describes how Meely and other Joint
Chiefs discussed a plan to resign one by one
rather than carry out orders from Trump that
they considered to be illegal, dangerous or
ill advised.
This is absolutely incredible.
The book recounts.
The book recounts how, for the first time
in modern U.S. history, the nation's top military
officer, whose role is to advise the president,
was preparing for a showdown with the commander
in chief because he feared a coup attempt
after Trump lost the November election.
The author explained.
The authors explained Milli's growing concerns
that personnel moves that put Trump acolytes
in positions of power at the Pentagon after
the election, including the firing of Defense
Secretary Mark Esper and the resignation of
Attorney General William Barr, were the sign
of something sinister to come.
Milley spoke to friends, lawmakers and colleagues
about the threat of a coup, and the Joint
Chiefs chairman felt he had to be on guard
for what might come.
Quote, They may try, but they're not going
to effing succeed, Milley told his deputies.
You can't do this without the military.
You can't do this without the CIA and the
FBI are the guys with the guns.
This is how much those at the centers of power
feared that this was what Donald Trump was
going to attempt to do.
Now, Donald Trump reacted to this report and
put out a statement saying, despite massive
voter fraud and irregularities during the
20 20 presidential election scam that we are
now seeing play out in very big and important
states, I never threatened or spoke about
to anyone a coup of our government.
So ridiculous.
Sorry to inform you, but an election is my
form of coup.
And if I was going to do a coup, one of the
last people I would want to do it with is
General Mark Milley.
He got his.
Job only because the world's most overrated
general, James Mattis, could not stand him,
had no respect for him and would not recommend
him to me, the fact that Mattis didn't like
him, just like Obama didn't like him and actually
fired me, he was a good thing, not a bad thing.
Trump going on to say, in any event, I lost
respect for familie when we walked together
to St. John's Church, which was still smoldering
from a radical liberal radical left fire set
the day before side by side.
And the following day, Emily choked like a
dog in front of the fake news when they told
him they thought he should not have been walking
with the president, which turned out to be
incorrect.
He apologized profusely on and on.
Certainly not the type of person I would be
talking CU with.
I'm not into Koo's.
So what's fascinating about this is that Trump
did seem to want a coup.
It just seems maybe he wasn't planning to
use the military.
But Milli's larger point was correct, which
was Trump and the movement tried to subvert
the election through potentially illegal and
violent means.
It's horrifying.
It's absolutely dystopian.
And the the the real coup attempt was saying
you won an election, you lost and sending
lawyers around even incompetent ones like
Rudy Giuliani and Sidney Powell and Janet
Ellis to try to steal it back.
That's the horrifying reality.
He tried it.
He would try it again.
And the fact that he lost or wasn't able to
do it is why he's now using this language.
But absolutely crazy stuff.
I actually do plan to read this book.
I alone can fix it.
I never read these types of books.
I didn't read the Woodward ones.
I didn't read the Michael Wolff ones.
I just have so much other stuff history, sociology,
philosophy on my my stack of books to read.
But the Lenegan Rucker book seems very much
worth reading and they're typically quick
read.
So I do plan to check it out.